[Musique]
al mon
trés la Réunion bienvenue l'émission n
cas n trésor chez Monsieur magdoline
dans la commune de saint-pul trou un
trés est destiné à la séparation de
produits par chauffage puis
parroidissement allez viens ça bonjour
monsurdine bonjour Comment est ça va en
forme en forme alors dismoi ici c'est qu
de la trésor mon trésor c'est mon
alambique ah et ça c'est alambique un
alambique il fait il sert à faire des
huiles essentielles et ça fait que ça
après l'huile essentielleuile
essentielle en général il fait des
parfums avec et aussi la médecine en
aromatathérapie beaucoup de gens il
soignent avec les huiles essentielles
ganium les B tout ce qui moustique gê m
à miel les boutons de fièvre quand ça
commence à picoter met juste une trace
il arrête tout de suite développer mais
comment ça son un alamb d' cour mais je
veux bien que nous les 3è génération et
cette alomque là c'estàd tu appartient
mon grand-père son tu un peu plus bas et
il a don moins pr la ramène ici c'est
les Gillard mais ça fait mon grand-père
fait fait géranium et après mon papa
fait géranium et ça transmett àprè ou
pas ah bien s en ce moment est en train
deoccuper un hectare un peu plus loin
c'est est chouette et ben en ce moment
en train de travaill dedans alors mais
comment il fonctionne sur la Lamb ma de
laine mais dans C com un gros marmite je
veux bien nous mettent de l'eau dedans
après il mettent le ganum
nous mettent le couvert le col dessine
le tu il traverse là le
serpentin le serpentin dans l're bac et
il ressort du STO après je veux bien
comme les NAT fe la vapur d'eau il passe
entre la masse végétale train
l'essentiel arrivver là-bas il fait la
condensation la vapur d'eau il devient
l'ydr là et la VAP il devient l'huile
vert et après la séparation se fait dans
le vas juste en dessous nous à la rion n
appelle essencier d'accord c'estàd
l'huile comme les plus léger il monte
dans la bouteille et le trop plein d'eau
il ça va dans la Ros juste à côté on va
dire il 5h de temps mais ça fait
l'essenel après monsieur mdoline une
fois n l' tout distilé en général c'est
la coopérative récupère toutes les huile
essentielle de l'île et cette
coopérative revend ça à la ville de
grâce comme toutes les parfumeries se
trouve à grâce et la médecine en
aromathérapie aussi ça fait beaucoup de
gens se soignent aussi aux huilees
essentiellesand qu làen géranium ça fait
nous fait géranium nous fait cryptomia
nous fait campf eucalyptus romarin cpré
citronnel et là en ce moment il vient de
mettre 5000 m² en ver monsieur mcdoline
un joli petit cas raconte Mo un petit
peu cette histoire là ben le petit cas
est là c'est une petit cas
traditionnelle tu bien là mon grandm
elle avait une petit case en bois soutol
il était en calimétressé et ça fait
motiv faire un petit case pareil dans
cette zone là et là je vais bien les
poteau les fait avec ce bois là là le
bois NIR là ben crypt Meria d'accord et
après avec les toutes les tresses là ça
c'est une variété de bambou il com il
trouve uniquement dans les haut de
l'Ouest ici et il commence à pousser
entre 900 jusqu'à 1800 m d'altitude et
ça on parti récupérer dans la forêt
juste à côté et après l'emène là et la
fond all en de commence le ban TR et moi
all et ça ce qu'allumé là à peu près 35
ans il est là pas bougé du tout et même
les portes c'est planch cryptoma les
fait avec d'accord et toujours grandi
dans la case là 1 an làdedans non madame
et puis TR marmaill chou et en un an
justement il tombe bien c'est souvenir
mon meilleur souvenir là c'estàd le
matin lever mon Bran Bran et puis nettoy
un petit peu la c juste juste tout un pe
devant par ici les Gillard ah tu plaisir
ben oui et dismi depuis que tu habites
là là mais c'est quel endroit tu
préfères le plus case ah mon petit
préfère le plus c'est c mon all là-bas
tu es là le soir en hiver le soir tu es
là M un TR boisess et pu t gris patate
DESS ah gr patate dans la S patate douce
d'accord même certaines personnes
aussici plant Jani tu grill aussi chou
dedans dans la S devant la Lambé là ben
les gaillant en tout cas ah non était
bien bon monsieur mdoline en tout cas
merci d'avoir comm cas merci pour
partageentendre bon affaires trouvé ça
c'était un plaisir d'accueillir ça et
puis la prochaine correct allez bye par
contre là oublie pas faire mon petit
portage s'il vous plaît mais bon
salut et ben voilà notre émission l'
fini pouri V la case monsieur mdol avit
un magnifique trésor son la L et la cas
mais pas fini continu la Réunion d'A cas
et d'res
trésorouve tout mon trésor m'aé
méé
mon mon
oui
monabar mon nation